Here is an incredible paper that teaches virtual
humans to run in the most fabulous ways. So good!
So, what is this? How did we get here? These are
large language models, text-based AI systems that
can be our smart assistant, someone who can
draw images for us, we all know that. However,
fewer Fellow Scholars know that they are also
excellent at reading and writing computer code,
and can thus, even learn to play Minecraft. That
is incredible. Just think about it: this is a
text-based AI, how could it possibly control
a graphical game like this? Really amazing.
So, at this point, we know what
these large language models can
do. The age of surprises is over…or
so I thought! Dear Fellow Scholars,
this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Previous AI-based techniques can play Atari games,
and other games at a superhuman level. They
typically do it through reinforcement learning,
which means that they get a controller, look at
the screen and play like a human would. DeepMind’s
techniques are excellent at this, and thus,
they already do extremely well on these games.
However, there is a huge problem. What is the
problem? Well, look. Scores. Games have scores.
And these scores can be used as feedback for the
AI to understand whether it is doing well or not.
High score, doing well, lower score, not so much.
And whatever other task we wish it to perform,
there needs to be a score. There needs to be
feedback. And therein lies the problem. Each
game has a different scoring mechanism,
and thus, each task needs a different
scoring mechanism. If we are aiming to create an
intelligence of sorts, any kind of intelligence
requires generality. So it has to be able to
perform tasks it hasn’t seen before. But how?
Scientists at NVIDIA had a crazy idea. Let’s
use these ChatGPT-ish large language models
to write code to calculate the score for
these tasks by itself. Wow. I love it. But,
does it work? I think that cannot possibly work,
there are just too many kinds of tasks out
there. Well, let’s have a look together.
Now, little AI, write code for the score
for this humanoid to run and then, train
it. Well, what can I say… it works. Well,
look, no one said it has to be beautiful.
We said it has to run. Running is making
progress moving forward. It recognized that,
and this already works, and the
whole thing was written by an AI.
Now, get this. Let’s try this
some other way. First, little AI,
design a task where forward movement is
necessary. Wow. That is a fabulous way of
moving forward. Now let’s give it some feedback:
This looks like squat jumps, make the movement
resemble running a little more. So the AI says,
okay, got it, so you mean a duck walk! Well,
not quite! New feedback: the torso has
to be a little higher. Okay, good. But,
it is using mostly one leg to hop on. Please use
both legs. Goodness! Both legs are now being used,
but look. Hoo boy! Back to square one. Now the
torso is too low again, let’s ask it to penalize
that, and…there we go. Finally, something that
resembles running. It is not an easy task at all,
it turns out. And, this human feedback-driven
solution I think is way better than the AI on its
own. This intelligence of sorts is wonderful,
but human intelligence is where it’s at.
What a fantastic paper! But, it gets better.
In fact, here comes the best part! This concept
generalizes to so many tasks, from passing balls
to balancing them, teaching robots to move,
and even the crows favorite: spinning pens. Very
impressive. But, how does this train so well and
so quickly? The key is that this learns within a
computer simulation which has two advantages: one,
it can’t really harm itself, and two, my favorite:
in the real world, one second means one second,
but in a virtual world, one real second can be
simulated much quicker, given a powerful computer.
A little game can be simulated quicker. How much
quicker? Well, in this case, this little AI is
learning a thousand times quicker in a simulation
than it would in the real world. So cool!
And it gets even better. Hold on
to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because it can not only match the
level of humans playing these games,
but the evolution-based variant can even
showcase superhuman performance. Wow! It
matches or exceeds the level of humans on 75%
of the dexterity-based tasks. That is insanity.
Finally, an AI that can do these tasks and
have some sort of generality. What we are
seeing here is perhaps the early days of true
intelligence being born. And all this within
a little piece of silicon, and lots and lots of
human ingenuity. What a time to be alive! However,
it is a research work, and it is not
perfect. Not even close. For instance,
please don’t ask it to close your doors. Ouch.